hello can you guys hear me
kimbally calm down
can you hear me kimbally
we hear you oozman we're giving
everybody a little bit of a break
good good good start listen to me
because it's like i was thinking they
caught up the voice no usually all
daughter second i am telling you this
zara and i we don't even talk okay
usman
hold that thought we're gonna give kim a
minute okay
all right
mom
huh
oh come here
you're doing great you're doing great
don't get your makeup on
after everything i did
to call zara is a slap in my face
i just feel like that just hit me out of
nowhere i don't even know like what do i
do now do i make it work now i mean
we're in a relationship
gusman's always been honest with me and
and forthcoming about things but i feel
like with that
i didn't know
i don't i don't know what to say right
now my head is just spinning
so
i will um address this later
definitely
back
thank you very much for joining us
kim's heading to that right now
okay
sorry it's okay sweetie
thank you um
[Music]
tell me what you're thinking
i didn't know about that
i just
[Music]
you